SOMETHING TRIBAL, CHINESE?
I DON'T DO CURSE WORDS
IN ANY LANGUAGE.
- WELL, WE ARE LOOKING
TO BUY SOMETHING
SO WE MAY...
SMOKEY-BOO?
- BECAUSE WE'VE RUN OUT
OF THINGS THAT WE...
SCHMOOO.
- WHAT ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
- WE WANT TO BUY
SOME WEEEEERD,
SO THAT WE CAN PUT IT
IN OUR BEEERD AND SMEERRK IT.
[all talking at once
in code]
- SMAKE IN A PAT.
- GET AN APPLE,
AND THEN WE CAN SHMEEK.
- GUYS.
[chuckles]
LOVE THE ENERGY,
BUT YOU CAN'T HANG OUT HERE.
THIS SPACE
IS FOR CUSTOMERS.
- OKAY.
AAH! HAA!
- THERE WE GO.
- AAH.
OH, IT LOOKS SO BEAUTIFUL.
- YEAH.
- PRINCESS.
- OH, THAT HURT A LITTLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT
WOULD NUMB THE PAIN?
WEED.
- OH, HO, HO.
YOU GOT THE WRONG GUY, PAL.
[tattoo gun whirring]
- OKAY, HE WINKED EARLIER.
THAT WAS--CAN I AT LEAST GET
THE STUD THAT I PAID FOR?
I'M BUMMED, DUDE.
THIS IS A BUST.
- ADAM, THIS IS NOT A BUST.
YOU GOT A BANGING-ASS
BELLYBUTTON RING, BRO.
- YES, YOU DID.
- HONESTLY...
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
IF I'M GONNA KEEP IT.
- OH, COME--DON'T SAY THAT.
- ADAM, COME ON.
- IT'S BANGING-ASS.
- COME ON.
- BANGING-ASS.
IT'S LAME-ASS.
- HEARD WHAT YOU GUYS
WERE ASKING FOR.
MIGHT BE ABLE
TO HELP YOU OUT.
MEET ME OUT BACK
IN TEN MINUTES.
[ominous music]
- HEY.
- MAKE IT 15.